there is a
growing talking point
that
there is an assassination plot
against donald trump now
almost certainly
there are people who would love to
assassinate
every former president and every current
president
joe biden gets assassination threats
trump got them
barack obama got more than any previous
president george w bush got them okay so
in some general sense
the point of the secret service among
other things is to track and pay
attention to and investigate
assassination threats against a former
or sitting president
but there is a growing talking point
among the american right wing the maga
people
that the fbi raid on trump's home
is part of
a growing assassination plot now before
we even look at the clips and the first
clip is going to be from uh from steve
bannon
you have to at some point
apply
some basic level of critical thinking to
this stuff and you should be saying
if there was an assassination plot
against donald trump
why would a legally executed search
warrant on his home
be part of the assassination plot why
why would you need that if you're i mean
for the people that believe that the cia
killed john f kennedy
why would they have needed to first
serve a search warrant on his hyannis
port home or the kennedy compound or
whatever it just doesn't make sense you
don't need a legal fbi raid as part of
an assassination plot but this doesn't
matter to them this doesn't stop them
let's look at this first clip and by the
way if it's steve bannon so it's not
merely an assassination plot it's a deep
state assassination plot take a look at
this
and i agree i do not think it's beyond
uh this administrative state and their
deep state apparatus to to actually try
to uh work on the assassination of
president trump i i think people i think
everything's on the table i think his
security ought to be at the highest has
ever been in and honestly i think he
ought to and i think he should have
flown down in mar-a-lago this morning
walked out there at noon today and said
hey i'm running for president united
states suck on that
well that was my next question as his
former top advisor what should trump be
doing right now right
i think what we did what he should do is
action action action i don't think there
should be any more of the tweets no more
of the true social stuff that's all nice
listen there's not going to be any
tweets he's been banned from twitter for
a long time they put out a video last
night no more videos
we're beyond that
you know they're they're trying to not
just put you in bankruptcy
they're trying to liquidate
uh infowars which is obviously one of
the major news sources out there for uh
the maga movement they're trying to
liquidate
um infowars they're putting peter
navarro in chains like a common uh felon
all right so anyway the deep state is
working to assassinate donald trump and
there's been planted materials at
mar-a-lago no evidence of any of that
stuff then on newsmax and we looked at
this earlier in the week here's bernie
carrick and i should actually be precise
about bernie carrick because i alluded
to this and then i was not completely
sure about it
bernie carrick is former police
commissioner
but also a convict he pleaded guilty in
bronx supreme court to ethics violations
and acknowledge that when he was
interior minister of iraq he accepted a
quarter million dollar interest-free
quote loan and loan is in quotes it's
not really clear what the deal is with
that then he was indicted by a federal
grand jury the following year in white
plains new york on charges of tax fraud
making false statements in 2009 he then
pleaded guilty to eight felony tax and
false statement charge this guy if this
guy if anybody knows about criminality
it's bernie carrick and he is on to say
i think they may be trying to
assassinate trump with all of this and
again the question is bernie you used to
be in law enforcement
why do you need to execute a search
warrant in order to assassinate someone
and i just put out a tweet about this
if you remember back in 2016 when i when
right before he got elected i was in
washington dc i was at a couple
different social events and i hear
people talking
they said the democrats want this guy so
bad
that they wouldn't put assassination
behind it
and i'm going to tell you something
please they've tried impeachment
they've tried another impeachment
they've tried one investigation after
another
this is about one thing
this is about stopping him from running
in 2024. and i'm going to tell you
something i'm not into conspiracies
right i'm not into
anti-government rhetoric
this is the first time in my lifetime
that i would say i am deathly afraid for
donald trump i would not put
assassination
behind these people i i just you know
make a very good point bernie he gets
secret service for the rest of his life
based on what we have known recently
where we hear about deep state he may
find it in his best interest to get his
own security with the secretary
understand that
the deep state may be so deep
it may be in the secret service the
secret service may have it out for trump
and thus trump should have private
security to protect him from the secret
service which is there to protect them
from everybody else as well bernie about
20 seconds left final thought
listen i couldn't agree more
you know what just happened is no
different than happens in venezuela
colombia cuba and countries like that
unfortunately it really doesn't happen
in a lot of those countries in a lot of
those countries you would never see a
search warrant conducted
on a current or former official you
wouldn't see it because they actually
don't have the the the administrations
control law enforcement and they control
courts and these are the horrible things
in some of the places that they talk
about so you actually would not see that
no evidence for any of this no evidence
for any of this but they're talking
about planted evidence they're talking
about assassinations they will not stop
and they are throwing everything they
can at the wall to see what sticks we'll
have more coverage of all of this on our
facebook make sure
that you have uh found our facebook page
facebook.com davidpakmanshow and
remember that if you've been missing all
this week we've been doing live streams
covering the latest revelations on all
of this if you've been missing the live
streams you can see the top clips from
the live streams on the second youtube
channel that channel is called pacman
live and you can find it at youtube.com
slash pacman live believe it or not
that's where you can find it
don't miss the live stream coverage we
will take a quick break and be right
back much more news to discuss today